I came out to my mom earlier this year
but
she kind of like ignored it and like
when I talked to her about this she was
like oh they might set you up with a
real nice man
I was like oh yeah
um
[Music]
hey good humans Timmy here if you're
like me I take my skincare routine
seriously no like actually seriously
this portion of the video is sponsored
by Neutrogena but that doesn't mean that
I don't like to keep it as simple as
much as possible when setting a routine
finding a cleanser that's gentle on your
skin and doesn't dry you out can be
difficult but when you do find it it's
like first love and a fave of mind that
I've been loving lately is today's
sponsor neutrogena's Hydro Boost Gel
Cleanser
with the formula that lathers so nicely
rinse is clean and can come fragrance
free it easily checks off all the boxes
I look for in a staple cleanser suitable
for dry skin check sensitive skin done
acne prone you got it and its secret
ingredient the hyaluronic acid formula
that's clinically proven to improve
overall skin appearance and feelings of
skin sensitivity in four weeks seriously
nothing beats the freshness I feel every
morning when I wash my face and the
sense of relief I get when taking off my
face at the end of the day clean silky
and soft
shop the Hydro Boost Gel Cleanser online
or at your nearest store and let's be
skincare besties click the link in the
description box below to find out where
you can get yours today thank you to
Neutrogena for sponsoring this portion
of the video now let's get into the
video
hi my name is Amanda pack I'm 22 years
old I'm a filmmaker and my love print is
rwpg
hi my name is Carrie I'm 25 years old
I'm a founder of a non-profit and I also
work in public policy and my love print
type is ripg
so I have been in a series of like
longer term relationships I personally
love love so if you were to ask my
friends they'd be like Carrie Falls
really easily I also idealize and uh
often get hurt because of that I don't
know if I'm proud of that but that is
what happens I've been single for like
almost five years so
I've seen two people in a romantic
relationship just really unconditionally
love and support each other and I think
I'm personally ready to give and receive
that kind of unconditional love and
support
foreign
tea I would love some tea this is so
gorgeous let's do it oh oh
yeah cheers okay
that's good it is good it is very good
yeah I like it yeah I love your pants by
the way thank you I love your
outfits
do you wanna you can yes I can I can
kick it off oh my goodness let's go
let's do it okay what item has the most
fundamental value to you it's a little
embarrassing to me but I'm just gonna go
for it but um I have like the the
blanket that my parents used for me like
when I was born I still have that
blanket with me it's like a comfort like
piece for me I was gonna say how's the
condition of it right now no I would not
show that on camera okay that
is a Sentimental thing I think are meant
to be kept like just close close to the
heart yeah it goes the heart away from
the world that's good I don't know if
she knows that I have it but I have it
it's a ring for my grandmother I love
any like item that's passed on for me I
have such a bigger appreciation for it
now than I think I did when I was
younger but I'm embarrassed to admit it
because I keep losing it but it always
gets down maybe it's like it's involved
for like I'll always find my way even if
I get lost no that's a beautiful story
thank you where the hell is that right
here it's in my room it's in my room
next one
oh no okay what is your most terrible
memory
what is my most terrible memory terrible
is quite an adjective as well okay I'll
just give like an overview of like the
themes of it rather than going into
detail but I think my most terrible
memories are love related which is like
shitty but like you know it's like it is
like uh what it is for me and a lot of
folks I know um and particularly
memories of like me you know trusting
that a space is safe and it ended up not
being safe
um whether that was you know with you
know family relationships in the future
so safety I think is a very
interesting word that I think I've also
been yeah thinking about a lot more in
terms of like relationships just like in
any space Where You're vulnerable or
intimate you know when I think about
maybe my most terrible memories it was
kind of somewhat of like where my trust
was betrayed or and I think in a lot of
ways when your trust is betrayed you
know you don't feel safe yeah I've been
framing my life in like kind of like
with safety in a lot of ways so it was
really interesting about that can I ask
a follow-up question to that like what
is what is it that makes you feel safe
and comfortable I'm a very like
gut person like I feel safe from like a
feeling you know that feeling of
security that someone sees me and
yeah I think there's like a tenderness
to safety too
um it does take a long time in order for
me to feel safe I think that that's
something
that needs to be built for sure okay
first can I ask you what color you are
oh I am the color grape oh I'm pistachio
oh let's go into it okay I'm like pretty
guarded
uh yeah I guess how do you feel about
being assessed as guarded yeah I mean I
think it's pretty accurate in in the
beginning and perhaps very willing and
open and then something happens and I'm
like oh my God no I can't I don't know
if I could do this and then I get really
scared I also I was like this is very
accurate you know I know that I'm a very
guarded person and I think it just
protects me emotionally from things and
I think no one else is going to look out
for me and my emotions except for me I
guess has always been the posture that
I've held about that what's your motto
there are no words
oh it's a little romantic and I feel
like I like romance so I also like
romance but that being said my motto is
give me a teeny bit of space
oh my goodness okay okay let's see
what's going on oh
this one's nice what is your most
treasured memory oh okay
I see what they're doing yeah I see the
map is nothing this is gonna sound a
little nerdy and lame but I think it was
when I got the acceptance letter from
the college that I ended up going to it
was just like a really gratifying moment
for me where I felt like a lot of the
intentional work that I put in paid off
yeah in a way the one that comes to my
mind
and I always like struggle thinking
about this without like tearing up but I
will try to not tear up this time and I
can do it no worries I can do it my mom
and I went on like a trip with just the
two of us to Disneyland which is like
not much of a group like kind of close
to me I don't remember a lot of my
childhood but one memory that I do
remember a lot is my mom and I like
sitting in like the little like
storybook Gondola and like looking at
the miniature little princess thing I
remember thinking back at that time when
I was a little bit older I was like why
did my mom
just take me in like Disneyland's a lot
of money to like you know there's
there's just so many factors in her
being able to do that for me that was a
really really happy time for me so
shout out to my mom
okay oh wait it's you oh is it I think
it's you it's me
when was the last time that you really
cried
oh
I cry a lot but right now they're like
little cries like little you know just
like
so I think the last time that I really
cried was probably the beginning of this
year I was tailing off of like a
situationship I have a lot of trouble
with intimacy just generally I think it
was a situation where I didn't feel very
safe so on my way back from
feeling that way my best cries are in a
car it's like dark All Too Well Taylor
Swift 10 minute version came out you
just want to direct yourself exactly and
I was like you know what I'm doing this
on purpose like and so that happened so
that was that what about you oh it was
last night
um I I had I was talking with my mom I
kind of got into an argument with her
um I'm non-binary I use they them
pronouns and so I feel like
I came out to my mom earlier this year
but
she kind of like ignored it and like
when I talked to her about this she was
like oh they might set you up with a
real nice man like you know I was like
oh yeah
you get to a point where I was talking
with my mom and I was like did you ever
consider that this date would not be
with a man and then she was like is it
not with him and I was like Mom I
literally don't know
um similarly uh with my mom I like
came out to her
not on like my own terms
um we're in that stage where she's not
really acknowledging and she's also like
I met this boy at church today you
should read it and I'm like girl firstly
even a different do we have the same
idea
it's not that she's doubled down on it
after you know we sort of had a
conversation about bisexuality but I
don't know if I'm at that point where I
can have a head-on conversation be like
well what if I bring home somebody
that's not a man
I don't know if it's much of a
conversation whereas like just me kind
of like stating the facts and she's just
like
I don't know it's you know it's hard
anyway okay next question
um what does it actually mean to be
vulnerable with your partner
that is a good question I think
vulnerability is both working to create
mutually safe spaces uh for each other
and also working to like communicate not
just in the way that you like to be
Community or like I would like to be
communicated with but also me
creating a space where they feel
comfortable communicating as well
vulnerability is definitely a two-way
street you know like both sides have to
kind of be equally working and I think
that that can be a hard balance to find
um
Thinking Beyond just myself
is a big one too I think that's a sign
that like you're maybe ready to be
vulnerable or that this is someone that
you know you maybe
desire to be vulnerable with
okay you will now experience four
minutes of eye contact and complete
silence great cool okay
all right so close your eyes take a deep
breath
and begin
[Music]
oh you're so good
at first I left because that's like my
visceral reaction so I was like oh no
and then I got really anxious
to be honest I'm not too uncomfortable
in silences silence is kind of are like
you know a mark of safety almost
sometimes
foreign
I can definitely see how that Fosters a
deeper Bond because that's really
vulnerable it's just to like stare at
each other for so long
in the beginning half I mainly focused
on looking at her
but then there were like moments in the
second half where I kind of let myself
be seen by her
I'm really sitting here like looking
into the eyes of another person I don't
know where this will go but I feel you
you know so yeah
I didn't know
like how vulnerable I was gonna be but I
think I ended up like sharing a bit more
than I thought I would and I think that
was a lot due to
you know
Carrie and like
the person she was
um yeah
now
you have to make a decision oh you can
go back in if you feel like you want to
continue exploring this relationship
romantically
or you can leave right now if you don't
feel like there's a true romantic
connection
do you have any
idea which way you want to go
[Music]
should I read the letter
okay
it was sealed
Carrie I feel so lucky to have shared
this experience with you
I loved getting to know you in such a
safe and intimate way
you are a special human
I know that for sure
in terms of a romantic future I'm not
too confident but on a human to human
level I'd love to get to know you more
[Music]
can I talk
no I mean I think that feels good I
think like this is you know I wasn't
expecting any sort of
outcome in any way and I think I was you
know just lucky to have this experience
as well that's what she said here so or
what they said there yeah this is good
[Music]
thank you
foreign